[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being here how are you I'm
fine thank you for having me thank you
so much for being here H well I'm
excited to get to know you better you
you have quite a quite a really
interesting background in the context of
of marketing and social and and
messaging and how to get information
across tell me a little bit about your
background and and we'll quickly lead
into what's happening over the last few
months really since the the start of the
war yeah so uh my I guess business
Journey Begins very early very young uh
started to coding website when I was 14
and uh short short after this after that
I started to get into marketing as the
way I found to really first express
myself and I really like the creativity
in the marketing field and second of all
I think the mo most important is the
fact that in marketing I could uh create
campaigns and and sell products that uh
continue selling while I'm doing other
things and that's for me for my uh 15 1
14 years old it was really uh different
thing that I didn't know exist tell tell
me a little bit about about what you've
been up to over these years so more more
tangibly what what did you discover and
and what were some these projects so I
started with affiliate marketing uh
selling other people products getting
commissions and few years after that uh
I started also teaching Marketing Online
and really got into the digital digital
knowledge digital courses and um all of
the this type of Industry when you uh
sell knowledge online and really you we
mastered how we can uh show the best
message to the best people across many
platforms and getting making sure that
people can actually learn online and and
learn and again because you know there's
a lot of uh unprofessional courses or
things that in this
industry like for sure dig digital
knowledge is a revolutionary but in the
early days of when I got into it uh it
wasn't so accessible to everyone uh so
what we did we we tried our best to make
it more accessible and that's what I did
until I was 18 and then uh you know I I
born and raised in Israel and for sure
18 is the the age you going to the Army
and I didn't really knew if I wanted to
do it or not people people offer me to
some solutions to uh not go to the Army
and continuing my business and continue
making money uh and I was like I wasn't
sure what I going to do and then I I I
went to Poland with my High
School uh and when I saw you know the
the camps in Germany in h in Poland and
I really and learn about all the
Holocaust I I realized that for sure I
want to close the business and going
into the army and going to be a combat
Soldier so that's what I did uh and
after the Army when I released I was
like I did Regular service and after
that I started to do high-tech and I I
came back to the marketing but from and
the advertising business but from the
technology perspective of advertising
Technologies and stuff like
that very cool wow okay so leading up to
to the start of the war what what were
you doing right right before then so
what was your position because you
mentioned that you you had a you you you
were nominated as the as the CEO um of
the company that you were working at so
tell me a little bit about the context
of what's what's your life looking like
right at the beginning of the war yeah
so October 7th you know c c us all by
surprise uh and for me it was I wasn't I
was actually in in the beginning of my
journey as CEO of fed freeway Israel and
I started to open the market and and
getting people to know Ed freeway and
know our technology and suddenly and and
like for it's totally normal no one and
especially not me was interested in
advertising and marketing and selling
products online and stuff like that you
know and that we all was shocked and
terrified of what's Happening uh but we
had this idea me and and my team had
this idea what if we can uh use our
technology our unique advertising
technology that can uh buy ads
programmatically anywhere in the world
and really uh make the make sure that
the best message reached the right
people uh what if we can use it in in
advocacy and what if we we use it
because you know in the first days when
if you open Al jazer you you would see
articles that Hamas didn't kidnap people
that Hamas didn't that the Freedom
Fighters of Hamas didn't do anything
wrong to civilians and just attack some
IDF
bases and actually people you know a lot
of people believe in it uh and we
thought to ourself what if we can take
those El
jazia all of the negative articles and
put our truth inside of them inject uh
hostage pictures and in
inject proof of what happened in October
7th inside those articles so that was
the slingshot pilot and we did it and we
I think the first pilot we got into
millions of views that like inside El
jaer inside inside places that the
Israeli side never you know it's never
showing up and we and and I think that's
that's what that that's was the time
that we realized that what we're doing
is really powerful because no one else
was doing that everyone on the aspar is
attacking social media and fighting on
social media but it's it's a it's uphill
battle because you can see that like
each Israeli post has like 100 less 100
times less uh viewers and shares than
the pro Palestinian post it's it's the
numbers game and we losing it we H 50
million people against two billions and
that's only like the the base uh the
yeah
M very very cool so so walk me through a
little bit you mentioned the The
Narrative and the problem that ues in
the beginning what what was sort of the
really the pilot consisting of how did
you started from a technological
perspective how did you identify whether
there were interesting points um of of
impact that you were able to do that
that gave you signals that you want to
go to do this
further so s today is we we call it iron
doome against anti-Semitism and to
understand the technology you need to
understand understand first what
happening now in anti-Semitism and we
all seeing the like the rise of
anti-Semitism all over the world and
it's very concerning but the a lot of
people think that the rise in
anti-Semitism happened because people
hate us and that's only part of the
truth but the bigger part of the truth
and what's happening and if you uh do a
little bit of research you will find out
that most of the the people that
chanting from The River To The Sea and
globalized in most of the crime hates
done by people to Jews they they're done
by people that don't know the facts and
actually that that's not when you tell
them and when when you show them facts
and when you sit with them so for sure
some people will hate you no no matter
what you will show them but a lot of
people just not aware of the facts the
simple facts of what happened on October
7th why Israel uh started a war on Gaza
uh and what what happened what happened
between the wars what happened before
the wars is Israelis making genocide in
Gaza when you show people the simple
image of the Gaza population just going
up and up and up in the uh last couple
of
years they they cannot argue with facts
sure some people will they had you know
no no matter what but a lot of people
and that's that's a thing that I found
surprising at the beginning they just
don't know when when you show them
you solve the problem so the real the
real problem in anti-Semitism is not
that people hate us it's just people
don't aware of the Israel Fox people
don't know what's happening what's
really happening because the social
media is like an echo chamber and the
traditional media mainly it's against us
uh so we had to find a way to to Really
to really amplify the Israeli voice
across other platforms and that's what
the slingshot technology does so we buy
ads on the open web which mean we buy
ads on more than 200,000 websites and
applications from the big one like Al
jazer BBC CNN to the small one and what
we know how to do in using Ed freeway
technology is we know how to when we run
a campaign and for now we running a
bring them home campaign they're
targeting specifically people in
Washington DC uh people highly
influential people so we know to take
this specific audience and we have like
five or 10 messages that we showing them
and our unique algor fre them can really
make sure that like it's not a in
marketing the first first first thing
marketer learning is about a testing we
are not doing AB testing we are making
sure that if we have 10 creativ is 10
messages we're making sure that each one
of them gets its ideal audience for them
so it's not like creative a or message a
is working for Israel better and
convincing more people it's like each
message has its own audience and this
audience get refreshed every two hours
and we we get this information we have
we our algorithm is based on an AI and
crowd wisdom and we we really uh
researching our users browsing patterns
and that's how we we know how to show
the right message to the right people so
it's two thing you know it's even more
than two things slingshot what slingshot
does is is few thing first is getting
the Israeli voice heard that's like it
it's never has done before and such so
many platforms second of all we can
Target specific geolocations so
neighborhoods college campuses and we
did it in the past in the in the icj in
the Colombia University campus in other
people when we know highly influential
people live that's one that's two and
and then we can buy ads and really
create high frequency campaigns that no
like you can you know when you're
walking on streets in New York and
people reaping off hostage posters
uh that they cannot do it with slingshot
ads it's like it's like signs it's it's
posters that cannot be reap off or
ignored uh so we and and then we amplify
it on in on our algorithm and we create
this highly impact slingshot
campaigns so who's funding this because
all this is obviously not a not a
business proposition per se right I mean
a lot of This is er there is an
important mission that that we're all
we're all behind but how how are you
funding this and and how has it been
over the last eight I guess nine months
this point yeah so that's a great
question that's the question everyone
asking who funding it because yeah ads
cost a lot of money and especially
especially if they're like high highly
targeted and all of that and we trying
to make a revolution in asaran we
actually doing it for profit and we
actually building a business model that
based on people who care about
anti-Semitism so we actually selling ads
to people and we allowing our customers
to select their campaigns and to support
campaigns they like so for example if we
going to a community in New York and
we're showing them campaigns that we
running we allow them to uh we allow we
allow them to contribute to the campaign
and actually buy uh Impressions and
that's the product we're selling we
selling people that uh seeing the
Israeli voice and and if your grand if
your grand grandson is uh in Colombia
University and and suffering for
anti-Semitism and suddenly we present
you with a way for him to get his voice
back you know to to fight for because
because a lot of them just feel afraid
to to share their voice and slingshot is
like a it's like a way for them to
amplify their voices and to fight for
what's right and what's not not what for
what's right and what's not
and uh and a lot of people you know it's
it's surprising because why do you care
why why would you buy ads but yes people
care and people see that you know if you
want if you if we don't solve
anti-Semitism right now if we don't do
anything we can it's just one war and
for sure it it would be nice if if
people would would do it for free but
you know we managing a team and we want
to do something that that is sustainable
even one year or two year even even five
years after the war
uh we see the the situation right now
when everyone is against us it's
happening because of of billions of
dollars and and several years of
influence against Israel in the academy
in in the polit in in the media in in
the political sides of things uh in
order to fight back we need to build a
different model uh so that's why yes we
we startup company we are for profit and
we selling to people for to people who
cares about anti-Semitic M and we
allowing them to affect uh how to affect
things in their neighborhood in their
college campuses and that's it and and
so where where do you see this you know
in the long term is the I guess are are
you viewing slingshot as a short-term
project or or is a long-term one you
know I hope I hope it will last many
years and our vision for slingshot is to
really be the digital online voice of
Israel and the iron against
anti-Semitism and why we chose the
against anti-Semitism is because you
know it's reacting to each narrative and
and countering countering it live and
the way to do it is working with
communities and working with people who
actually care so the way I'm viewing it
the the way slingshot I want I want it
to be in the future uh is actually
people like you like me that creating
communities and creating their own
campaigns we at slingshot we understand
that you know the problem with Israel is
we we never lack of of content there's
so many content out there there's so
many uh facts and and Tru and and the
the problem is not uh the content the
problem is how you get it out there and
so that's why uh my vision for slingshot
is people taking their own content
whether it's social media influencers or
other organizations that already have
content and amplifying it on our
platform and building slingshot
campaigns uh and and you know working
together to solve anti-Semitism each one
where they where they can do
it amazing and this is such a such a
refreshing a experience I think that you
know i' I've seen a lot of entrepreneurs
go through the the start of the war and
and asking different questions but it
sounds like your your ability to take
the technology that you've been working
on and the products you've been working
on and adapting them to something that
that feels like a true calling right I
mean you're talking about the experience
of being there on that day and and
asking well what what am I doing this
for right I mean who cares right now
about you know about this this work that
I've done until now but hey I can
actually make it useful and make a
positive impact if I adapt it to this
new use case and there is obviously a
market for that as well yeah and you
know I didn't I didn't chose to do it I
didn't I didn't thought I would do it
and the truth I I did it because no one
else is doing it and you know for people
that I'm talking with I also want to say
look if you if you afraid of
anti-Semitism and you see what's going
on and in it's only get going to get
worse and nobody's coming to save you uh
so I I hope that my solution actually
can help because in the first time we
can we know what we doing you know a lot
of organizations doing advocacy but they
don't really they they can't measure
their impact they can't measure the
success and using our online technology
we in the first time we can we can
Target people we can show results we can
show Impressions and and clicks and
votes and we know what which message
work best so yes I I for like it's
what's happening in in the US today it's
really it's really it's woring us all
all uh but for the first time I I feel
like we might have a solution yes we
need to pay for it yes it's not no it's
not for free but if you care about your
childrens if you care about what's
happening now if you care about being a
Jewish and not uh not being afraid
walking on the street with
keepa we got to do it m and wishing you
best of luck thank you so much for the
time and for the energy and I look
forward to continue following from the
side thank you very much thank you very
much thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]